The joe rogan experience.
Ari Mother fucking Shit.
Fear has a billboard.
If there was a movie about your life,
um,
and then this happened the way it happened,
I would go,
ah,
they,
it,
I was too much.
Yeah,
too true.
Try it.
No Way.
Oh,
I had a billboard above where he lived for 10 years as he struggled as he was
fucking destitute,
living in this little shitty area of Hollywood.
13 x a year right next to the comedy store.
Right down the street from the comedy store is the cheapest housing near the
comedy store.
Yeah.
It was cool.
I remember every time I'd visit you and be like,
safe here,
can we walk through this thing?
All right.
You live with,
it wasn't dangerous,
but it was bad.
And then eventually the homeless people started moving in.
Yeah.
You lived with some sketchy folk.
There was a,
like a few people were like,
I didn't walk through your halls.
Like I would walk through the Ritz Carlton's pillow,
like I was on a,
I wouldn't say I'm a code red,
but I was on code yellow or whatever the fuck the Tamarisk code is.
I had a little bit of,
we had this,
these,
these horns.
It's kind of like that.
That bet Brady,
that chain you have there with the beads.
Yeah,
it was hanging up with this weird horn thing like on the railing in a corner and
I asked my friend there,
I was like,
how long has it been there?
It was before I moved in and were like,
do you wanna move it?
You fucking move it.
It just looked like Voodoo Jewish and we were like,
maybe it's keeping the place up and that thing was there for 10 12 years and you
haven't touched it and you had this great deal where this apartment,
like they wanted to turn it into something else and they want to sell it's prime
real estate sunset and Luciana go Sansone loss you to get,
if they put a dope apartment building up in there,
people would just kind of want to do.
But everyone above and the hill.
The Richie's got mad though.
Like you're going to block our view.
They're rich and they blocked it forever.
Plus,
even if it was like,
all right,
all the new ones that be no blockage of view,
I'm going to put a rooftop garden on there.
So all you'll see is greenery and flowers say about that.
Still not.
It's going to mess up traffic while you're building.
He goes,
yeah,
it is gonna mess up traffic a little.
And then he got a deal with pink dye goes,
how about we only enter through the pink dot parking lot?
And they were like,
still not.
Yeah,
that takes years,
right?
Yeah.
So then he finally got the okay.
People were moving out one by one.
He was given deals to people and he gave you a deal.
Gave me a deal.
I got the deal.
I think I might have been the last one to get the deal.
And there's a billboard.
This is not Ari's idea.
He didn't ask for this.
There's a billboard above his old fucking apartment and the billboard above your
old fucking apartment.
This is not happening with you.
Got Brow Fun.
I have pictures of me.
Fuck an eagle.
This is America.
We will you will.
You are in that picture on my Instagram.
Look at that picture because you can see them.
They could see the window of my old,
of my old apartment.
Look at that picture.
I,
that's one of my favorite pictures of all time.
Look at that fucking picture.
Man.
You're so happy you did it.
That is,
that's officially you did it.
Was that last night Jeremy?
No.
Oh,
I mean if you go off the wall crazy and uh,
jump off a fucking building.
I had a billboard in my feet.
Did it?
Yeah.
That's pretty,
I don't know.
I've gotten so much.
People are so much more excited about this.
Then the show or the special,
well,
the show's awesome.
You know,
shows awesome.
It's great.
But there's something so nutty about the visual of that billboard above your old
apartment.
The fact that it's right there is so god damn crazy.
That's your fucking apartment.
Look at that.
Where my head is sticking out.
That's mine.
That's my bedroom window.
This is insane.
This is like some real weird simulation shit
that's so fucking weird.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
You wouldn't think in a movie.
You'd be like,
no fucking way.
I've never been happier for someone else.
Thanks that then watching this happen to you.
I've never been happier.
It's,
it's amazing to see,
dude.
It's so cool.
It's so fucking cool.
It's wild.
It's just stuff that doesn't even seem like,
like again,
if that was in a movie and be like,
come on,
they put a fucking billboard right next to the apartment and he'd be like,
no way man.
Come on.
Make it down the street.
That would still be something.
Yeah,
and it would be like a conspiracy theory.
Oh,
he fucking course.
He told them he wanted the billboard above his old apartment.
It's,
it's the comedy central bill,
but they bought it like five years ago and they've been putting stuff up there.
By the way.
You lived there way before that.
Exactly.
Do it that,
but man,
it sucked.
Also walking under it going like,
fuck,
oh,
show billboard.
I wished I could get one one day.
Wow.
What a fucking crazy
be alive.
That must've been,
you have to give him to religion or die
easy and she shows you that people have always had that weird desire to have
everyone else think exactly the way they thought and it makes them feel more
secure.
Christians,
more Christmas.
It's more Christians.
Jews actually never proselytized don't.
That's amazing,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Why is that?
Because your religion,
it's silly.
Is anybody else's based in the same things?
Yeah,
it was a question.
How come they figured out to like keep to themselves and you don't have to do
this.
There's no reason you should.
If you want to,
you can,
but we're not going to try to push it.
I was like,
do whatever you want.
But time of David,
they outlawed it.
Outlawed conversion.
Wow.
It was too popular.
Too popular.
But he wanted to be a judge.
You just,
because it was like they were the ruling party really.
Damn.
So they outlawed it.
So they said no conversion during this time.
God for how long was your no,
please.
I'm fucking,
yeah,
I don't know.
Now you have to do that.
You have to ask a bunch of times.
I'm just hanging out.
I don't like these people to that.
Most of the whites.
I don't want to be that.
Every,
you pretty much have to do that.
The Rabi I'll tell you like,
don't,
don't do this.
You don't want to do it really any big macs.
We can't just trust me.
You don't want to do those 20 big macs if you're had Judy can't eat big MACs,
religious Jew,
you know you're supposed to eat hamburger.
Is that what it is?
It's not pushing me.
And it's cheese on there too.
Oh,
so just that in general.
But you could have kosher beef burgers.
You could have a kosher beef burger with soy cheese.
Oh,
the cheese.
What does it,
you can't combine milk and meat.
Is that what it is?
What's that all about?
It's pretty much a stupidity.
It's just like all the religions.
But uh,
it's based on a passage that says you shall not mix the meat of the mother or
the milk of the milk of the mother with the meat of the calf.
Huh?
Yeah.
Horn instead or anything else?
Some sex tech that just to be that it's,
it's that actual mother and calf.
Yeah,
but that's the case.
Why can't you get the milk from the mother and then kill the mother and he heard
some milk of the mother and the meat of the mother.
That's all right.
I don't run it.
Really.
Got It.
They just no meat and milk.
You have to wait.
If you eat pizza,
you have to wait 30 minutes for you meet.
What are the odds though,
if I have a fucking piece of meat that the nugs going to come from the same?
No,
it's not.
They said that means they said that passage means don't mix it two at all.
Fuck you.
Linen and cotton.
You can't mix.
Yeah,
but you can't.
If you're,
if you have a,
if you have like a a woolen the linen,
that's what it is.
If you have a wool jacket,
you can't have linen things tying in the buttons cause that's evil and you'll go
to hell for now.
My favorite one.
My favorite one that you told me to this day was that you were told that when
you masturbate for that,
people don't really know.
Ari grew up extremely religious to the point where he lived.
You lived on lives in Israel and your show for two years.
Yeah,
I mean that's the Torah all day long.
Nine p on the 10 9:00 AM to 10:00 PM I mean dad is,
that's some pretty intense shit.
And they told you when you masturbated that you were impregnating a demon and
let's just say you're on your back lying down.
They didn't really do positions back then in our shower anyway,
but when you're doing it,
some demon comes and like,
she's like a round you fucking you as you're fucking your hand.
Yeah.
And then you make like demon babies and they have some writer uses the phage.
There was some like maybe Dean Koontz sh everything.
Coons use it in a movie or some deep know in a book.
There's some,
some demon was like writing them and had anyway,
but then you get her pregnant and she has babies every time you do that.
Every time you're 100% as babies.
Never going to be one on earth.
They only live in this demon world and Delta formed and gross.
Wow.
I forgot about this.
And then when you get to go to heaven,
when you die,
you have to meet those demons.
Oh my God.
And they got,
Why dad?
Why couldn't we born on the regular planet?
Wow.
Why are we like this dad?
So did you masturbate to,
anyway,
even knowing all this,
and what did you think was,
was this going on?
Why you were living in this like really religious environment?
You were asking me and you never saw him masturbating.
You never stop.
I mean,
I slowed down.
I thought it was evil for doing it.
Well,
like,
so you're doing this,
you're there 9:00 AM to 9:00 PM did you think,
well that part's bullshit.
You,
you're studying like this intense religious,
well there's,
I think there's two types of scents.
Literally.
This is how it is since 2000 since there,
since you plan out and say fuck it.
I don't,
I don't agree with that.
And this types like gossip where it just happens.
You're not thinking about it like fuck,
I shouldn't have done that.
Right.
Talking about about somebody's masturbation is one that it just overcomes you,
but it's one,
I guess it's one that you do plan out cause you could just not do it this time.
Oh,
you accidentally touched it.
Women I don't think have the same.
It's not theirs.
They don't have that backup.
You know women want to have sex,
they get itchy.
They want do they want it to be touched?
They want affection to get horny.
But we have like a backup of sperm where like your Dick is like,
come on,
let's go.
It's like you got to get rid of this shit.
Jesus Christ.
We can't even think you can sour milk from everywhere here.
Come on Jesus.
What did you,
when you beat off did you like fuck?
What about those babies?
Did you believe that part?
That part was more like fables is wasn't like the written Toro was like this is
what's,
this is what like the extra curricular,
stuff like that.
So when would they bring that up?
How'd you they barely brought that up.
Did they bring it up in class ever?
Yeah,
it would come up.
We're in discussions with rabbis who studied all that stuff that the,
the um,
the Zahar Zahar when just like the mystical book,
but you're not supposed to say that until you're married and 35,
what is it?
Second Mystical Book and said you can't sell it until you're married and 35 at
least set up about it.
It's got all the stuff about ghosts and weird shit.
Ghosts does go Siemens crossing dude,
Judaism.
Sounds like fun.
Literate.
You don't get to read it very much.
I never read the translations.
I was just so hard.
Maybe I should read it.
Can you get it online?
Can you babied by now?
It's probably all written down somewhere actually,
but a lot of it would be the exact language.
You wouldn't get that from transaction.
You look at clothes.
Yeah.
There was this piece,
there was this one piece and a in the Talmud,
which is like a respect to like you're supposed to study apart.
And they said this,
rob,
this rabbi,
I went to his students who were living in like a dormitory altogether because
there was a snake or a dragon that was attacking them every night and killing
his students.
So he had his sleep and only the rabbi,
it was one who gets to feed it.
So he had to sleep under one of their beds,
um,
so that he could kill this dragon.
It was a dragon.
And I asked my rabbi about that.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this all about?
Uh,
it's my way.
What's going on?
Does not seconds dragons.
This is all under this bed to suck your cock.
And that's how I killed the Dragon.
Yeah.
He said there was a rash,
there was a rash of jerk offs going on.
And the only way that he did,
they can't really write that out in the Talmud.
So they had a metaphor.
It was a rash of jerk offs.
And the only way I could stop it.
It's a rabbi hiding under the bed saying,
I call you.
You're masturbating.
Wow.
So the dragon that was killing off the children was just them masturbating,
desire to masturbate.
Oh my God.
Their spiritual selves.
Holy Shit.
That's Hilarious,
Mia.
But it's not written.
That metaphor is not explained.
It's just,
it's just assumed and you have to ask someone who understands the tax or Rashi,
but it looked quite stuff about it.
If you can understand that.
That's so crazy,
man.
Well,
how would that in the future,
people would just think it's just craziness.
This was an oral tradition too,
so it wasn't even written down.
Someone just had to tell you that story.
Wow.
That's what they wrote down when they thought they were going to lose it all.
That's amazing.
Wow.
That
is a great fucking story,
I think to be making that up,
but I'm really not.
It's hilarious.
We're so crazy.
Have you had your man period lately?
No.
What's that?
And I have this theory that when we shit,
then it's all bloody in there that it's possible that he does it.
At the same time like it's based on the moon.
How often do you guys,
shit when you get the one year,
shit happens,
happens every couple of months.
It goes for like a week week.
Those are the hemorrhoid thing.
Oh my God.
And then you wipe and you just like,
ah,
I'm still wiping a lot of shit.
You're like,
no,
it's just soaking red blood.
That's all.
There's no shame in it.
Die On your hand and go straight through the toilet paper.
You guys both need to go to a doctor together and find out what aliens are
raping you in the [inaudible] Shit study.
Imagine what you a fucking camera over your bed.
That's what really watched aliens come in the room and take you through the
walls in the middle of the night.
Return you later.
It's sometimes when you stand up at your toilet seat.
Looks like Dexter,
like,
like the blood spots that you know from.
It didn't go in the water if you have too low and if you guys are both shit,
not that much blood.
Yeah,
I mean it pours.
It's the warmth.
It's like a warm faucet,
just take a beaker and turn it over real beaker and turn it over like about that
amount of the shot for the shot girls.
Those like about that much water.
Not something to be proud of.
You guys are both really sick.
Jamie.
You okay over there?
Are you and I in the same boat?
I can tell you this though.
I did have a massive diarrhea problem last week.
It was really worst diarrhea problem a long time.
I do not know multiple days or one diarrhea multiple days.
I don't know if it was a stomach cold.
I don't know if it was something that I ate that didn't agree with me but it was
like one day I had a headache and my my,
I was like wow,
I feel so I think it's like a food poisoning issue cause I had an ha a headache
and I was like,
man,
I feel weak.
It was the Hannibal.
No,
definitely not.
Definitely for that.
Yeah it was.
Um,
no it was,
it was post ham but I hadn't eaten a ham for days.
But it definitely wasn't that.
It was something that it had I think that day or before that day anyways,
diarrhea.
Oh my goodness mean it was more than a week after I'd eaten the Ham.
Now that I think about it.
Did you mix it with the regular dump and have like a no dude,
it was just over the,
this is what happened or whatever was going on inside.
My stomach was converting everything.
I ate into this liquid and I didn't even make sense.
It was like defined physics.
How solidified was it?
It was water.
If you dropped it on a UN inclined table at a 40 degree in client,
would it go straight off the table?
Take a minute to go ride like a fucking great wave straight through great brown
wave of destruction.
Dude.
It would rumble.
My stomach would rumble and then I would go,
oh shit and I'd have to really bathroom.
Then I'd get to the,
and I would hold it up in commercials like listen,
I would,
there's no way I was brave enough to fart.
There was no way.
There was no way cause I would get into that tub or get it all over the bowl
rather and it would just hear whoosh,
uh,
just water tub shooting out of my ass.
Wow.
Complete water for like two days and then it became like very untrustworthy
shit.
I feel solid swarth day.
Yeah.
And I got hemorrhoids.
I had to go get preparation h oh no I bought squeezing it and pushing it,
trying to get it to come out for so long,
which is really bad.
Pushed air bubbles into your asshole.
Well I think,
you know,
squeezing your ass like that,
trying to poop is very bad for you.
You're not supposed to do that.
And that's apparently one of the things that causes hemorrhoids.
Log dumps.
So then,
but the preparation h is a mother fucker dude.
Cause one day of that cleared it right up really,
really quickly to get the cooling like cool ranch.
When are the cool
for cool ranch sense?
Smell refreshing.
Find out people are like putting it on food.
You can't eat that sir.
It tastes just like it.
Preparation h measured preparation h was totally edible.
Yeah.
Whatever it does it,
it really works good at fixing any sort of a hemorrhoid situation.
He got down there,
they went away like within a day.
But man for fucking days,
four days of totally untrustworthy shits,
the pasty shit where it's like you could spread it on brick.
Oh I could spread it.
Yeah it was like leaves in there and shit cause I still eat healthy but it was
like a lot of liquid.
It was some sort of a stomach bug,
whatever it was.
Um,
I don't have any idea where it came from food or whether it came from just
catching a cold and you know,
that this cold manifested itself as a stomach bug,
but whatever it was,
man,
it was crazy for a few day and I felt real weak.
Like I'd go to pull my bow back and it was like kind of difficult to pull the
bow back.
Cause you're waiting from stumping.
Yeah,
I was weak.
Like I would like pick things out having,
yeah,
I could feel it.
Her friends.
Yeah,
definitely dehydrated but also just I wasn't eating right.
Like I was scared.
No,
I wasn't getting hungry either.
I mean I was eating right in that I was to having like lettuce and salads and
stuff like that,
but I wasn't eating very much.
I wasn't eating like,
uh,
like light meals during the day because my stomach was so untrustworthy.
When that happened with diarrhea,
what is it?
What's happening?
I don't know man,
but whatever it was just digesting it just too much.
I would eat like a steak.
I would have steak and some salad and it would turn it a water.
Like how does steak and a salad become?
I mean my,
my body was liquefying it and they would come out just whoa,
what is that?
That's,
is it too much stomach acid that just breaking down and write everything and Mel
session,
I don't know the process.
I should probably know that you should have shut shit on your hand a little bit
and sort of smelled it right then and see if it was that well,
I took us some on it.
Enzymes on enzymes are all in a digestion on it.
Pippy piles.
That's how it got me out of it.
God.
I just had to do the time.
I just had to let my body process.
It sounds you just drink a lot of water put in the Reps.
Yeah,
it was.
I was definitely thinking that I was probably getting dehydrated from,
I was like so much water's coming out of my ass like I better make sure I just
drink a lot to go with it.
All right.
Does your hemorrhoid it happens is do you even feel that the hemorrhage,
cause I can still feel it.
I feel like it's like,
oh I still have,
there's still some stuff I've got to wipe off really like,
oh it's just my mind.
Just a little while.
My bleeds I go away cause like a giant tour.
That's just my ass now my,
that's my shit right there.
It feels like what leads out.
It doesn't even feel anything.
It just,
that's that wheel that exploded inside or isn't it in a way inside.
Don't even feel it.
Mindset.
They're a diet that you can take stops that from happening.
Probably stopped behind hemorrhoids.
Finding foods.
Stop eating from Jack's
lodge up inside your anal binding foods and stay away from them or eat a lot of
them.
I forget what it is.
Oh well you should probably know it's one of those two.
So rice was in that group.
Binding foods are definitely away from him or keep eat a lot of them.
I don't really go by the regimen,
but if you do do that it would help prevent hemorrhoids.
Um,
yes,
that's my dogs don't want to.
Got It.
And um,
that's the knights.
Do you need a lot of salads?
Research?
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
Does that help at all?
I don't know.
I feel like it makes you shit more often.
Yeah.
But if you,
um,
if you doesn't it come out like we need a lot of salads.
It comes out real easy.
Woo.
Oh right.
Yeah.
That's I guess a scraping,
pushing.
I used to pray it was so jacket,
it'd be so jacket that I would pray to have it come out cause it hurts so bad.
Oh that's horrible.
That was so inflamed in there.
Cause I was just wasn't dumping because I knew it would be bad.
So I was like,
let me hold it for another few days.
Oh my God.
Days of dumping
held off from days at a time.
That's insane.
Shit.
Every week.
Dude.
That is so insane.
That's so insane.
I've never even heard that's toxic.
I guess so for sure.
You're containing all that stuff in your body.
It's supposed to be evacuated.
Well it's in that spot.
Whatever.
That spot is.
Not Rubber.
It fucking filled up dump,
but it we become too big for my ow.
Ow.
Jesus separate.
It's like your first time,
your first time doing it.
Ain't no,
you fucked men go.
It's like,
that's pretty much what it was.
Might use the asshole and it was probably all dried up in there.
Right?
Right up.
Oh yeah,
try.
Yeah.
Pizza.
Jagat Chuck Tearing you apart is your shit.
I would have to reach in some times in terror.
Oh,
you had to do that.
Oh my God.
This is a,
Jamie's been top five William Deval songs.
Last couple of why that looks.
Where with the three d glasses on.
I'm not happy with these
positive.
We get it.
We get it sounds like a white guy.
Yeah.
Sounds like planes.
But yeah,
we got it.
How's your ball's been Ari?
Everything down style because we never write to you about your,
your balls and your butts and stuff like that.
Thought I had herpes.
Oh that's right.
Really positive.
I had herpes.
I mean really positive.
Like what was the symptom log on to one is 10 at 10 I was in nine.
I go,
it was like fuck.
Well I got herpes,
the Sims is where I saw a scab on my dick and I was like,
well that's,
and then I looked it up on Google on images.
What else do you think it is?
Herpes,
herpes,
herpes scars or whatever.
Herpes outbreaks and it didn't look like most of them.
It looked about like one out of like 10 of them are real life case.
Never had them before,
but I was like,
look,
I'm not the most careful guy in the world.
I mean condoms,
condoms.
Uh,
so I was like,
well look,
it's caught up to me.
I guess this is,
this is fucking,
you know,
get it now.
It's better than I got when I was 25.
I wish right now we could play.
Damn,
it feels good to be a gangster.
See in 10 different countries at least.
Oh is it a bunch of countries.
And I was like,
look,
this could have happened at any point,
but I narrowed it down to who I thought he probably was.
I called like three or four girls or girls.
Hey,
I think I have herpes.
Uh,
uh,
you should,
you should go get tested and stop fucking Damon.
Like why am I have a outbreak?
I have a herpes out,
but there's no way there's anything else.
I have a herpes outbreak.
Yeah.
Cause what else could it be?
You just don't wake up and have a scab.
Exactly.
And um,
so I scheduled the blood work,
get everything taken care of and in the meantime we can know what's going to
take us.
It's over Christmas weekend,
so it's going to take longer.
And then while I was hanging out,
I was hanging out the stand.
How many club?
Maybe the best club in New York,
but I'm talking to the owner and Pete Lee,
this comedian and tell them my problem.
And Pete was like,
you know I had,
where is it like right underneath the hood of Your Dick?
I'm like,
yeah,
right there.
He's like,
I had something like this once.
It was like a penile tear.
Have you done anything like rough lately?
And I was like,
yeah,
actually I noticed it right after unlubricated anal sex.
That's when I first noticed it,
but it just didn't go away.
And lucky you're alive.
I'm lucky I'm alive.
And that's what it turned out to be.
How do you have unlubricated anal sex?
That's like fucking hard,
bro.
Hard.
I mean,
I know spit,
you didn't spit on the task force was wet.
It was wet or duck.
And that jug is delayed.
Yeah,
you get it wet and then you can fucking go for it.
I don't know this,
but yeah,
when she got to do,
but you just believed commercial lubricate.
So relieved.
Yeah.
And I'm telling you,
if you think your wife has been happy when you've called before,
after fucking three days on the road and not being able to call,
you've never heard.
You tell a girl,
oh I was wrong.
You don't have herpes.
They get elated overcome with joy.
Now do you think maybe you should have just waited till the results came back
showing these guys and you just didn't want them to fuck somebody else in the
meantime and then while I'm waiting to side some other guy's life is ruined.
Right?
Well I heard this is the Mesil suck it up and take my lumps also on the other
level,
I figured I could tell them I'm 90% sure it was like a cop out.
So I'm not like fully saying,
look,
I have it.
We fucked.
I thought that,
uh,
from what I understood when I got tested was that you can only test herpes while
the outbreaks happen.
Then the act actually spoon a little out of the outbursts that you can't really,
it's really hard to test for herpes.
So a lot of times you can get tested during like not an outbreak and be like,
oh yeah.
And you wanted,
which was positive for herpes?
No,
I think it was an old tests.
I think that was like 15 years ago.
Toast.
They need Olympic style.
Herbie's tough
for serious overcome his boy.
And
I'd heard if you do pop it like you could actually taste it.
It tastes herpes.
Yeah.
It's like a sweetness.
How many different fucking woes before herpes is like,
I got it.
Yeah.
You can't just say it's the ones that might just be that buzz Sauvignon blog.
This person has had it for a while and treated,
it's a burgundy
burgundy's the on
culture swiffer around like a penis in your hand.
Look at the legs and that Herbie,
ah,
how?
How many,
how many herpes is you have to build a taste to be able to taste herpes.
They figured out a way to train dogs to smell cancer.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Okay.